[Music]
I've been to a lot of different places
in the world so be honest there's might
be my favorite city I've ever been to
[Music]
I love art the way you dress people have
different ideas of what and how they
should express themselves
[Music]
seeing a lot of vibrant colors and a lot
of brands who think it's just time to
step into that light
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that was more of a preciate for
designers and brands after you get to go
to the show the black ones like
aesthetic is off my live
there's a lot of people looking up to
you a lot of people consider your role
model and I felt obligated to carry that
in the sunlight it's humbling to be
honest to be halfway across the world
people still want to take a picture with
you is truly like heartwarming I've
always liked classic simple basic earth
tones - colors
[Music]
just seeing that person and being able
to be a fly on the wall and taking all
that information he just kissed the
girls tried it for me I've broken
barriers this week here finally in
confidence with my fashion
[Music]
like maybe one day I'll be designing
that fashion we can have long so you
know we're so close to something
I just bought a book a little bit store
when is that closer Harris that was more
but as I get older I'll learn to like
live and that pain no just use it as
like you will
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
there's been a lot of great stuff all
week this is probably more inspirational
pieces of points in my life
I can see myself coming back I think
Paris is just not psycho Bob is very
smooth elegant very graceful city I can
almost see myself living here